[Applause]
sixers have denied young that little
floater thus far curry nice point
sevens on a break away simmons throws it
down
nope the foul call prior to
like a review too clear path or not
they'll
check that
so they're going to look at this here
yep yeah once college on the floor is a
clear path
[Applause]
go back to that last play by trae young
again tried to get the ball into clint
capela on the baseline facing embiid
they probably would have been better
served to pull it back out knowing that
capella not only in this game but
last game as well has been having
problems finishing around the rim
see right here all right now you want to
dump it inside
i get the idea and concept but
understand who you're passing it to and
who's guarding them
now hence not a solid possession get it
back out turnover happens
called a clear path foul
two free throws in possession if it
stays that way
nate mcmillan imploring his team and you
know that conversation's about defense
that's where everything starts with
mcmillan
who's brought that defensive tenacity
to this team after replay review it is a
clear path foul two shots
all right so two shots in possession
here and
you know but i agree with you on the
defensive side what nate is saying
but right now offensively they got to
figure out ways to get some easy basket
to get some more clean looks they've had
some looks behind three but they haven't
been able to knock it in
but not being able to get those little
baskets that can help the momentum build
they haven't gotten and they haven't
gotten any like exciting plays yet
well it was on this floor in game one
remember someone's missing the first
hawks made 23 pointers in game one
and they have the shooters to do that
but we see it every year those rims
starting to tighten up
when you get into the playoffs crowd
trying to help out
ben simmons and he misses again he's
missing
five consecutive free throws now after
he made his first
and it'll be sixer ball on the clear
path foul
simmons now one for six he does have
three points he's got five assists in
the game
he was making a run at a triple double
in game four
and disappeared in the second half he
had just one field goal attempt he said
he needs to be more aggressive here in
game five
and they're gonna foul simmons and put
him back at the line
send it back down to stephanie reddy hey
guys i know there was some confusion
about what the officials were discussing
it turns out they were trying to figure
out
who at the time out should have been
charged to it was charged to philly so
they went from six to five time a month
okay thank you for that simmons knocks
down the free throw yeah i was so
curious
to know what that was about that's what
he said
right now
see